Pues los líderes de Inglaterra Alemania
Francia y Estados Unidos hablaron
discutieron sobre la situación en Rusia
y en un comunicado conjunto breve
comunicado que publicó la clase Blanca
dijo que están siendo informados de la
situación y que independientemente de lo
que estuviera pasando allá estos siguen
apoyando a Ucrania el apoyo es
incondicional a Ucrania por parte de la
casa blanca y de los países con los que
emitió este comunicado conjunto kamala
Harris que está en Carolina del Norte La
vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos en el
aniversario de el primer año después de
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia en el tema del aborto desde
allá se le trató de preguntar a kamala
Harris ella guardó silencio sin embargo
lo que se ha conocido es que tanto el
presidente Joe biden que está en este
momento en David han sido informados de
la situación hay un flujo constante de
información de los organismos de
seguridad nacional las agencias de
seguridad nacional y de defensa
estadounidense hacia el presidente y
hacia la vicepresidenta de hecho
tuvieron una llamada en la que estuvo
presente el Secretario de Defensa Austin
También estuvo en esta llamada asesor
nacional de seguridad nacional y esta
llamada fue precisamente con Joe biden y
con kamala Harris para informarles de la
situación la llamada También estuvo
presente y participó el secretario de
estado Anthony blin quien hace poco
llegó de su viaje de China y pues hasta
ahora esos dos han sido las
comunicaciones por parte de la Casa
Blanca por un lado el comunicado
conjunto con los aliados de El g7 Pero
por otro lado se conoce que hay un flujo
de comunicación constante entre sus
agencias y sus altos líderes y altos
oficiales de defensa de inteligencia con
el vicepresidente y con el presidente
Joe biden quien está en Campeche en este
momento